Dr. Kevin Cutters here again going over some more of your genetic profile that you're going to
get from us. This is kind of what your genetic profile will look like when you get our report
back from us. Now understand I get people watching these videos ago I did by 23 and my
email report doesn't look anything like that. Well because that's this is not what you get from
23 and me. So 23 and me gives you a lot of fluffy reports that are nice and fun but we have to dig
in and look at your different gene steps if we really want to help a person. So I need to take
your raw data from 23 and me put it into our software and come up with a report that looks
like this. Our reports are now over 30 pages long. My practitioner reports probably about 60 pages
long and this is what you're looking at right now as a screenshot of somebody's report practitioner
report on just the general SNPs. So this little video is going to be on the cartotene
transportation and your mitochondria. So under the section that says Krebs cycle or energy production
I think it says on the patient report thing. You're going to see a bunch of different families of
gene SNPs. Now the reason why these are important is these are all in your mitochondria. Every
single cell of your body has mitochondria. That was a little teeny organelles inside the cells
and every cell has hundreds and thousands of these mitochondria and their whole purpose is to make
energy. So if you're suffering from fatigue it can be tied to this genetic defects or these I
should say because there's a bunch of different pathways. So I'll try to keep this short. The first
pathway is the cartotene pathway and it's responsible for pulling fatty acids inside the cell
in order for these fatty acids to go through the fatty acid cycle that kicks out a ton of ATP
that kicks out a ton of energy. Now this person's got a lot of defects here. You see that? So this person
it may be very advantageous for this person to support these defects. See all these ones in here?
So they have some issues being able to get fatty acid inside the cell. Now if this was you I would
definitely be suggesting fatty acid assist, mitochondrial energy assist, or CBS, VHMT assist. These
all have cartotene in it, these products. I'd be suggesting one of those depending on other defects
that you have in this whole picture because I want to have you take the least amount of supplements
as humanly possible. But definitely supporting this would help a person's energy. Your
pake genes are also mitochondrial genes and producing energy in this person has some issues there.
So some pentathetic acid would be in order for this person as well. That's where fatty acid
assists in ALO formula, which is a fatty formula, getting good fats in that person's diet are going
to be important too. The ACAT gene is assumed for an important family of genes that can cause a lot
of issues with energy production. If you have defects this person certainly has a number of defects
there. The SLC and the ACSL genes also are mitochondrial genes. Now this person doesn't have a bad picture
here. So I would necessarily wouldn't support this. But the ACAT genes, they got a lot of defects
on there. This tends to be thought of as the most important one, this top one. They don't have a defect
on that. But if this person had symptoms of really bad chronic fatigue, I'd consider supporting this
pathway. The TLDO pathway and the OGDH pathway, all mitochondrial genes, how you handle fatty acids,
and alpha-ketogooliterate in your fatty acid cycle and in the CREM cycle in order to produce ATP.
Now this person isn't horrible, but they certainly have some defects there that if their symptoms were
were a big issue with chronic fatigue, now this person doesn't have a big issue with chronic fatigue.
And it's kind of suggestive of their gene profile because a lot of them are really, really clean.
So a lot of my patients have a lot worse genes than their mitochondrial genes than this person.
So these are your mitochondrial genes. Now there's other reasons why a person could have fatigue.
Definitely when we get down to looking at ability to absorb vitamin B12,
their iron levels, as their iron being oxidized, etc., etc., there's a lot of possible reasons.
But this is one of them. If they can't produce energy in their mitochondria because they can't get
you know glucose through the CREM cycle and glycolysis and fatty acids through the fatty acid cycle,
they're definitely going to have lower energy. So that's what these genes are when you look at those.
Great. I hope that helps. Thanks.